this video is sponsored by the leading
password manager
dashlane find out more later in the
video
hey 42 here in march 2019 archaeologists
in central china's henan province
were excavating the tomb of a noble
family from the western han dynasty
when they discovered an ancient bronze
pot
filled with a mysterious liquid it smelt
distinctly like
liquor so the researchers assumed it was
the last remnants of some kind of wicked
homebrew
luckily for them they resisted the
temptation to do a few
celebratory shots because further
analysis
confirmed the fluid was mainly made up
of potassium nitrate which these days
you'll mostly find in agricultural
supplements
rocket fuel and fireworks and
alunite a mineral modern folks like you
are more likely to put on your garden
than in your friday afternoon sundowner
so
what on earth were posh people 2 000
years ago doing drinking liquid
fertilizer
simple they were trying to live forever
the recipe for this concoction came from
an
ancient religious text that described
the makings
of an elixir of immortality and was part
of a chinese tradition of alchemy
thought to go back some 3 000 years the
yellow emperor a mythical leader who
ruled china from about 2700 bc
is said to have achieved immortality and
descended to heaven
partly thanks to his ingestion of a
magical potion
admittedly the same guy was reputed
to ride around in an ivory chariot drawn
by
dragons and surrounded by flocks of
phoenixes
so i'll forgive you if you're feeling a
little skeptical
but until as recently as the 18th
century
this story was serious business
alchemists dedicated their lives to
discovering the secrets of immortality
mostly in service of emperors who
fancied their chances of becoming
gods according to the 24 histories the
official books of chinese history
at least 10 emperors either died went
insane or were permanently incapacitated
thanks to drinking immortality elixirs
or taking pills most of which contained
ingredients like
mercury and arsenic which far from
making you live forever
dramatically decrease the odds of you
seeing out the day
naturally this madness wasn't only
happening in china
in the middle east and the west the
alchemical legend of the philosopher's
stone
a substance that could grant eternal
life and turn base metals into gold
dates back millennia some even say it
was handed to adam
by god himself buddhism and hinduism
also contain tales of a magical
wish-fulfilling jewel
called the kintamani stone which is said
to convey
immortality taken with a pinch of
metaphorical salt
these different traditions suggest the
human notion of
living forever has been around about as
long as notions themselves
even the epic of gilgamesh a 4 000 year
old mesopotamian script
regarded as the earliest surviving piece
of literature
is essentially the story of one guy's
search for immortality
and the friends he meets along the way
it's like disney
but on clay tablets the fact is humans
have been scared
to death of death for as long as we've
been conscious of it
and we've created endless myths and
legends
describing immortals or people who've
managed to
dodge the grim reaper for those of us
knee-deep in the 21st century
stories of alchemists brewing up toxic
nightcaps
may sound ludicrous but you have to
wonder if we've really changed all that
much since those days
because the topic of immortality is
hotter now than it's ever been before
and some people claim they've already
made it possible
companies have been around for years
selling cryogenic services
that allow you to have your head or
entire body
frozen when you die on the assumption
the technology needed to revive you
will be developed at some point in the
future
although of course what we're really
talking about there isn't so much
immortality as resurrecting the dead
forming out human popsicles and giving
them the full
frankenstein's monster treatment which
would be some serious technology indeed
perhaps more plausible if we can call it
that
is the suggestion that the human mind
could be uploaded
into digital form and whilst that also
sounds pretty
out there some people claim we'll
achieve this
unbelievable feat within the next three
decades this is the hope of
transhumanists
people who believe science will provide
a way
for us to transcend our physical
limitations
and access cyber immortality
we may not yet have cyber immortality
but at least you can have rock solid
cyber security
with dashlane who've kindly sponsored
today's video
dashlane creates strong and unique
passwords for all of your online
accounts
and auto fills them so you never have to
click forgot password ever again
and you don't have to sweat about the
extremely rare chance that dashlane
could be breached
because dashlane safely stores and
decrypts your data
on your local device only using your
master password
this means that dashlane never has
access to your personal data
and any hacker would only see random
noise dashlane also also fills your
credit card information whilst online
shopping
so you can make purchases without having
to fetch your wallet
dashlane has a built-in vpn to encrypt
your data
and keep your online activity anonymous
best of all
it works on any device whether you're
protecting your plans for a top secret
artificial intelligence or just videos
of your cat
there's no better way to make sure your
online world is
impenetrable than by using dashley
from my experience dashlane is the best
all bases covered security and time
saving tool out there you can try
dashlane for free on your first device
by heading to www.dashlane.com
forward slash 42 then
if you decide you want to upgrade to
premium use my code
42 for 10 off the idea of uploading your
brain to a computer
including all your thoughts feelings and
memories
is called whole brain emulation and
surprisingly enough
it's not a particularly new concept
similar ideas have been the fodder of
science fiction writers for almost 100
years
with legendary author arthur c clarke
describing a city
one billion years in the future in which
citizens exist
as data patterns in the city's central
computer clark
wrote that book the city and the stars
in 1956 but the reason we're having this
conversation today
is that rapid advances over the last few
decades in fields like
nanotechnology biotech and artificial
intelligence
have got people wondering with some
genuine interest
could we upload our brains and live
forever
and if we could how would we do it and
what would life look like
of course once we've answered all those
little chestnuts
the bigger question that remains is
should we one person who seems to have
answers to all of these questions
is ray kurzweil an american inventor and
futurist there's a moniker that gets
thrown around a lot these days
futurist in the past we used to call
them fortune tellers and make them sit
in caravans with crystal balls but
these days we give them book contracts
and consultancy packages
anyway even from this slightly cynical
starting point
there does seem to be something a bit
different about kurzweil
firstly he's a genuine visionary and
credible inventor
and is a past recipient of the national
medal of technology and innovation
the united states highest honor in
technology
he's also been making predictions about
the future for some time
with well-known examples being
nanotechnology
ebooks face recognition software and a
computer beating the human at
chess by the year 2000. by 2009
kurzweil had made 108 predictions
of which he claims 89 were absolutely
accurate with another 13 partially
correct
or set to be absolutely correct within a
few years
so he's developed a bit of a reputation
as someone who should be listened to
when it comes to development of the
future and the development kurzweil is
most passionate about is the singularity
the technological singularity is a
theoretical point in time
when technology will develop super
intelligence that allows it to upgrade
itself at an exponential rate making it
increasingly smarter
than us kurzweil says we humans will
then
merge our intelligence with machine
intelligence
and basically become super beings
and all of this will happen by the year
2045.
a key reason he thinks all this will be
possible
is because by the 2030s he believes
we humans will have transcended the need
for physical bodies and learnt to upload
our brains to computers
along with our personalities skills
and personal histories kurzweil appears
to be
genuinely convinced he's going to become
immortal
and takes more than 200 pills a day to
ensure he lives long enough
to see the technology that will turn him
into a digital
mini-me and he's not the only one
russian billionaire dmitry itzkov
has stated he's 100 positive he can make
humans immortal by 2045
by uploading people to artificial brains
these brains could then be dropped into
robots or projected as living holograms
or you could simply be uploaded into the
cloud where you could live out
your eternal life in a 3d simulation of
bliss
and bottomless digital pina coladas but
for any of this to happen we need to get
a few important things right
the first being the ability to scan the
entire human brain
to create something called the
connectome
a 3d map of the brain showing every
neuron and molecule
within there are big questions about
whether this would
ever be possible the brain is an
insanely complex piece of machinery that
we don't really understand all that well
yes even mine so far scientists have
only been able to map the connectome
of one creature a one millimeter round
worm
which has a total of 302 neurons
in its entire nervous system by
comparison
a fruit fly or ant has about 250
000 neurons a mouse has about 71 million
and the human brain has 86
billion today mapping of the brain
relies on technology like
mris megs and eegs
all of which give a partial but
incomplete picture
by a mile other potential scanning
methods include electrodes that could be
placed directly on the brain
with each electrode capable of mapping
thousands of neurons
but as this technique requires cutting
open the skull
it's no surprise people aren't exactly
queuing up to try it out
but let's say for argument's sake you
could find
someone crazy enough or drunk enough
to volunteer for this procedure and that
the operation was
even legal you could hypothetically get
a perfect biological image of the brain
but
would that represent the person you are
and
how would you actually make it run would
mapping the brain even be enough in the
first place
the human heart and gut are also
full of millions of neurons that have
been shown to affect our moods and state
of mind
but we need to find a way to upload
these too
if we go back to the example of the
roundworm its connectome was replicated
as software
and loaded into a lego robot which
the research team claimed behaved
exactly the same
as the original worm it moved towards
food and it responded to touch
but the robot exhibited no feelings and
didn't even cry at the end of titanic
so the question of emotional expression
remains unanswered
either way the human brain mapping
exercise would require computer power
capable of processing
vast amounts of data zettabytes in fact
how big is a zettabyte well if every
person living
in the year 2000 had had a 180 gigabyte
hard drive
completely filled with data all the data
on all of those drives
would occupy one zettabyte
it's the same amount of data as 200
trillion mp3s that's a lot of one
direction
and nobody wants that these days we have
some pretty
impressive computers take summit for
example
one of the fastest supercomputers on
planet earth today
to borrow an analogy from the new york
times
if a stadium built for 100 000 people
was full
and everyone in it had a modern laptop
it would take
20 such stadiums to match the computing
strength
of this machine summit fills a 000
square foot room
and has been clocked at just under 2
billion calculations per second
the fastest supercomputer in the world
fukaku
is almost three times as fast as that
but even this kind of
obscene technology doesn't even come
close to the processing power
we would need to create an accurate
virtual copy
of the brain it may be that quantum
computers can step up to the plate for
us on this one
but we're still trying to figure out
exactly what they can and can't do for
now
and it's hard to say for sure so yeah
the
hows of mind uploading are still yet to
be
entirely ironed out but for the sake of
argument let's assume these hurdles will
be overcome within the next few decades
and we manage to create true emulations
of human brains
what do we do next as we've already seen
we could pop our digital doppelgangers
into robots
or create mechanical versions of
ourselves but that relies on robots
evolving fast enough over the coming
years
for it to be worthwhile the most
advanced robots around at the moment
can climb stairs mix cocktails and
do gymnastics but they're still nowhere
near as agile and adaptable as your
average ape
hairless or otherwise the more likely
and probably
more affordable scenario for an average
person would be the creation of a
digital version
of you that could be loaded into a
simulated virtual reality
this digital world would require the
sensory complexity of
this one with the ability to replicate
all the ingredients
that make up the human experience sights
smells
tastes and textures even emotions and
thinking
yes we're basically going to have to
build
the matrix but unlike pre-red pill neo
the inhabitants of this world would know
full well it wasn't real
in the traditional sense and that would
allow us to code in some
serious upsides you wouldn't experience
death or disease unless you wanted to
you could fly
look however you want be with whoever
you want
go wherever you want basically a true
fantasy
universe like ready player one's oasis
but running an environment of such
complexity would
again rely on massive computing power
designing and optimizing it would almost
certainly require artificial
intelligence of some kind
and creating a continuous high quality
believable experience
would require giant technological
strides forward
for example the computer game industry
has fueled incredible advances in
graphics in recent decades
meaning it might be possible to make a
digital universe look
pretty great in the near future but for
obvious reasons no
real work has been done on how to
satisfy the other human senses like
smell touch and taste in a digital
setting
and even assuming we were able to meet
the technological demands to build a
satisfying and realistic digital
afterlife for
our uploaded minds how would that system
operate
it would require huge data centers
running 24 7
across massive networks in the same way
the cloud does now
but just as you have to pay a
subscription for your cloud storage each
month
you would presumably have to pay for the
storage
of your virtual self what if you were no
longer able to pay
would your data be switched off
effectively
killing you it's a system that feels
open to abuse
too it's the ultimate monopoly in the
real world
if you don't like the rules where you
live you can move somewhere else
but when your entire universe is owned
and managed by the same company
or organization if you don't like it
you're kind of screwed and nobody wants
mark zuckerberg
as their overlord then again these kinds
of challenges
only really matter if this digital being
is actually you in the first place
consider for a moment
the force experiment known as the ship
of theseus
if you aren't familiar with this one
just imagine the great greek heroes
vessel was anchored in a bay
as a museum relic but over time pieces
began to rot and were replaced gradually
more and more parts of the ship are
replaced until
eventually there are no original pieces
left
would the ship that was now anchored in
the harbour still
be theseus ship or is it something
different the fourth experiment was
first posed by greek philosopher
heraclitus
almost 2500 years ago to highlight the
question
of identity who are you
and it's been bugging philosophers ever
since
let's look at a more contemporary
example of the same conundrum
when crew aboard the starship enterprise
used a ship's transporter
their atoms are disassembled in one
place and then reassembled in another
if your whole body is dissolved and then
your atoms are reassembled somewhere
else
is it still you and if it is you where
are you during the time between
departure and arrival
whilst your atoms are separated and
drifting through space
there are two basic ways mind uploading
could be achieved
the first is the copy and paste approach
we've been looking at so far
in which we create a copy of the brain
and then upload it to the digital effort
the second method is to copy and delete
approach that sees individual neurons in
the brain
gradually replaced by computer functions
until
the original organic brain is fully
replaced
by a computer simulation just like
theseus's ship
in either case the question still
remains
is the virtual version of you well
you would we regard it as conscious
say you were able to create something
that was hypothetically identical to you
in every way same thoughts feelings
memories
likes dislikes weird fantasies about
swimming naked in jelly
and then you loaded that creation into a
simulated world in the cloud
who would be you the simulation or the
person
in your body or both the answers to
those questions
pretty much depend on your perspective
as far as your digital clone is
concerned a moment ago they were a
living breathing human being
and now they're a digital and immortal
super being
likewise to your friends and family or
anyone else looking
in from the outside your clone would be
indistinguishable from you and would
therefore
be you only digitalized and immortal
so far so good but from the final
perspective
your own things look a bit more grim
just because your brain has been
perfectly copied
it doesn't mean your consciousness will
magically jump from your body into the
computer
in fact you would go on experiencing the
world just
as you always did meaning you would grow
old
and you would die and the fact a perfect
digital copy of yourself
gets to have all the fun flying around
in the matrix
might not seem like all that much of a
consolation
in fact it might seem like kind of a
piss take
which means that even if we do manage to
overcome all the technological
ethical and practical challenges and
upload our minds
there are still serious questions to be
asked about whether or not
that would actually give us the kind of
immortality
we hoped it would in the first place
there are no simple solutions to these
questions
that's why we aren't doing it
philosophers have been kicking around
conundrums about identity
for millennia and we still don't have
answers we can all agree on
but perhaps that won't matter as far as
transhumanists are concerned
there's no need to let metaphysics get
in the way of progress
let's build cyber versions of ourselves
anyway and see what happens
we can sort out the definitions of words
like me and i
later still there's no avoiding that in
a future reality where uploaded versions
of people
are regarded as equivalent to physical
people
we will still need to answer some really
weird ethical questions
for example will simulated digital
versions of people
living eternal lives have the same
rights and responsibilities as people
living
in the physical world how will digital
people contribute to society
how will they earn money will they even
need to
with brain twisters like these to
contend with it's no wonder people like
ray kurzweil want to plug their minds
into computers
and access super intelligence whether
that will be possible
remains to be seen but first we have to
decide
whether it's even a good idea thanks for
watching
and thanks again to dashlane don't
forget to check them out
using the link below